all right so we're now live there were
some problems with this new YouTube
what are they call it live-streaming
interface I had the am a scheduled well
in advance just like I did with the test
earlier this week but it couldn't you
know I'd click on the button for go
alive and it wouldn't do anything I went
and played with all the different
settings and nothing has made any
difference so this is kind of a dud on
youtubes part I'm gonna have to go in
and figure out precisely how these live
sessions are supposed to be set up so
that you know users who don't want to
invest a ton of time like me into
figuring out how you know streaming
works and codes and all that other
nonsense can actually get on quite
easily so not super happy with the user
interface I'm gonna wait a few minutes
for people to come in we lost the old
questions that people were asking in
part because it looks like you know
we're basically on a different stream
now than the one that we had before so
I'm gonna look at some settings real
quick while people are writing questions
yeah it goes right to that that friggin
YouTube thing and I see both this stream
and the other one that was set up before
all right so we got some questions here
Azrael what does philosophy of economics
concerned with what are its big
questions any suggested reading not a
specialist in that area so I don't have
any suggested readings philosophy of
anything generally is going to be
looking at sort of you know foundational
questions and issues in that so whether
we're talking about philosophy of
economics philosophy of mathematics
philosophy of sport philosophy of
language there'll be a lot of questions
about entities that are taken for
granted within the discipline so within
economics you know you would have you
know questions about well what exactly
is supply what exactly is demand you
know these are nice
subtractions that people use but what do
they really mean when we're getting down
to it and then there's there's usually a
sort of history of the discipline you
know how did we get to this notion of
the economy and the presence as being
something very public when we can only K
it means household management in the
past and so those lots of questions like
that and and another thing that you do
see philosophy of X doing is questioning
basic assumptions that often get made
for example in economics there's this
sweeping assumption that human beings
are fundamentally rational agents and
that they make their their purchasing
decisions or investment decisions on
very rational basis and we know that
that's not always the case
so philosophy of economics would would
address that sort of thing ah Garden of
Eden what's your opinion on the guilt
argument from moral realism I don't know
what the guilt argument from moral
realism is I'm sure that's some like
little discourse and analytic philosophy
having to do with you know sort of meta
ethics or something not something I'm
conversing with if it's explained in
terms that aren't you know talking about
the ax argument I probably have some
insight into it
slam RN do I think Humes argument
against miracles is compelling no I
don't find most of humans arguments and
most of his works compelling that's that
I do find them interesting and well
worth studying you know you could you
could say that that and the same thing
that not only goes for like humans
arguments against miracles but in like
the diet the dialogues on natural
religion and the natural history of
religion the genetic accounts of where
people got their ideas from are often
quite interesting although you know turn
into generalizations you know you can't
really see how human can even give
himself given his you know
epistemological commitments in other
areas how he can give himself the
arguments that he is
so there's a bit of a referentiality
problem there but Hume also makes some
sweeping assumptions which again are
rather questionable so all right Robert
do I think philosophy and theology or
mortal enemies may be in the way
Heidegger thought I mean if we're
dependent on Heidegger's view for
understanding that this the disciplines
of philosophy and theology I think we're
in bad trouble because very few people
actually understand Heidegger very well
and I think you could say that Heidegger
thought that his philosophy and his view
on philosophy was in some way opposed to
theology but it was equally opposed to
ethics it was equally opposed to
rhetoric it was equally opposed to all
these other disciplines because
philosophy is sort of at the top you
know and then everything else is merely
regional ontology so if you're talking
about being in time all right and
there's a lot of people who do stuff
like that where you know philosophy is
like the discipline that tells everybody
else what to do and and those are
usually you know interesting but wrong
you know and it really depends when
you're asking this question there's no
such thing as theology and there's no
such thing as philosophy if you mean
some sort of entities that have this you
know clearly delineated order between
them if you look at the history of
philosophy you know Plato's doing
theology at some points right they
permeate each other and even the people
who are you know claiming to be totally
dispensing with the all you know
theological approaches and stuff like
that quite often isn't some you know
faith commitments that they're making so
you know it's better to speak of
theologies and philosophies
nobody-nobody within the field of
philosophy has ever provided a
definition of philosophy that even got
even close to consensus same thing goes
for theology as well and that's if we're
restricting it to Christian theology
right so you know it's not very helpful
to act about to ask about these gigantic
and astray
actions that are just that abstractions
you know which are sort of play
playthings of somebody's mind that may
not translate onto the way that the next
guy over there uses the terms so do are
they are they mortal enemies or you know
inevitably opposed to each other I don't
think so
there are certain people's
interpretations of theology where it's
inevitably opposed to philosophy but
that's usually because they're bad
theologians and there's equally a lot of
you know philosophical people say
theology you got to keep it out of here
and they say that about other things as
well but they're usually bad
philosophers so yeah srj in future of
half our Hegel well I'm gonna see the
project through
I've been extraordinarily busy this last
academic year I taught including the
summer 13 courses for four different
universities in addition I shot at least
200 videos that I've released and given
about 20 public talks just this summer I
shot over a hundred videos for my
business ethics class that I haven't
released so I'm you know an editing
stoicism today so I'm a pretty busy guy
and shooting videos on Hegel it takes
quite a lot I need to like not only
clear the time to do it and do the
editing and all that sort of stuff but I
have to have the headspace to do it so
that just has not been available in
addition you know there's been the usual
sort of issues with kids and travel and
you know we had to put one dog down last
Thanksgiving after a very in about a
year of some pretty intensive care for
him our other dog is is you know
inevitably going to die pretty soon and
she's had a lot of health problems so
you know there been things taking time
my goal is to get back on track shooting
half hour Haegele stuff and right now
we're near the end of the spirit section
of the work once we get that
accomplished there's just the religion
section which is big
but not as big as spirit or reason and
then there's that final set of
paragraphs that constitute absolute
knowing which which are you know kind of
underwhelming okay fine but yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna be getting on with it so
all right I'm gonna skip the question
about Jie Jie cuz I've talked about GG
Jack plenty of times I'm not very
interested in G Jack quite frankly and
you know time is short so I don't know
that it's really worth spending it on
you know reading too much of his stuff
yields are any central texts on logical
paradoxes I mean there's an anthology
out there that I've seen you know
paradoxes are a little are all over the
place and I don't think that there's a
theory of paradoxes I think that
paradoxes are of different sorts and you
you know you approach them with the
whatever apparatus you have and try to
make sense out of them I actually did my
my undergraduate thesis on the liars
paradox and other truths truth self
referential statement groups and showed
that if we're only considering things
from a truth self referential
perspective and not other values that we
can reduce all of them down to either
the liars paradox or to to a sort of a
consistent set of propositions and that
we can model the liars paradox with the
mobius strip but then after that I found
it quite boring and gave it up and
didn't really do any work with it
there's other paradoxes that are much
more more interesting I think but you
know you got to just look around within
the literature you'll find them are John
is what
after the subject that is if you agree
that it's dead I don't agree that the
subject is dead I don't agree about any
of these sort of sweeping statements of
this is dead we're beyond this this is
the new thing you know well they're
usually I mean you look back on the
history of ideas people have been making
you know methodological sweeping
assertions for centuries now about like
what's what's in what's out what we
can't do what we have to do all that
sort of stuff you know if you buy into
hegel hegel said you know nobody could
be an epicurean or stoic in the present
you know and then you know there's the
modern stoic movement where you know
arguably some of the people are you know
actually doing so in the present all
these sweeping assertions about you know
the death of the subject the death of
the author the death of anything
they're usually [ __ ] there's
somebody who's again you know you
approach philosophy from general but but
still particular sets of assumptions or
perspectives and so you know if you if
you read you know certain areas of
continental philosophy they'll tell you
that you know the subject is dead but
then the subject keeps going out and
just fine or you know metaphysics is
dead you know we have to get passed down
so theology or you know I mean think
about all the transformations and
analytic philosophy about what's no
longer philosophy and and you know the
stuff comes right back in so I don't
think it's very helpful to to frame
things in those ways Megara Cornelio how
to overcome your depression I began to
lose my passion for reading so far was
the only pleasure I had there isn't any
like recipe for overcoming depression
that works for everybody there are some
things that we know certainly play into
it but there's a there's a lot of
different causes for depression right
you could have a chemical imbalance in
your your brain and that might need to
be addressed through medication it could
also be you know because of cognitive
you know some negative self-talk or
assumptions that you're making which
then lead to effective states
and also you know tend to produce
certain experiences and which is
something you can work on on your own
but you can also work on with a
therapist or with you know self-help or
things like that depression is also we
know linked to the environmental and you
could say cultural factors or
situational factors you know if you grow
up with you know you grow up in an area
where there aren't many opportunities
it's it's easier to be depressed right
engagement with the world engagement
with learning about who you are
engagement with others engagement with
the physical environment those are
things that often help to alleviate
depression but there's no magic bullet
that automatically does it you know we
do know that that for example taking
walks in natural environments helps that
raises your mood of that exercise is a
great help and also good for other
things as well forming connections with
other people without expecting too much
of those connections is quite important
as well but if there's there's trauma
that you haven't dealt with then you you
have to figure out how to access that
understand it and then come to terms
with it and coming to terms with it
doesn't always mean getting you no
apologies from people who aren't suited
to giving it I can tell you that for
myself you know I've suffered from
depression really since my teenage years
and started you know getting getting
help for it in my 30s and you know I
still go I have times when I get I get
quite down and have that sort of a head
onea where you can't take pleasure in
things it's it's much more rare I'm also
very busy you know but I get to the
point sometimes where I'm like you know
man I'm sick of teaching this class and
talking about this stuff but you know
force of habits or that and since I'm a
duty driven kind of person that helps me
through it but you know I struggle with
it as well and I think sometimes finding
out that other people struggle in ways
you can be helpful as well so you know
I'm sorry to read that you're you're
depressed
to where reading books doesn't give you
pleasure but it won't always be like
that and you can find other things that
give you pleasure and you don't have to
place huge demands on yourself you know
the books you know like I have my guilty
pleasure reading that's what I do the
worlds of speculative fiction I'm
looking over there because my my Wagner
Kane novels are over there that I've
been reading you know when I when I
don't feel like reading other stuff
later on today I got to read some Cicero
in order to prep for some court concept
videos I'm looking forward to it but you
know sometimes I don't
hey so yeah all right crisco's America
great I'll be voting against Trump and
I'm a registered independent but I'm
gonna be voting probably straight
Democrat because I hate what he's done I
hate what the Republicans have done here
in Wisconsin so you and I are definitely
not on the same page Andre yes what's my
what's my view on Liberation Theology so
that was kind of a big thing when I was
in graduate school and I I thought it
was interesting I liked some of the
analyses that they had and I like the
emphasis on you know looking at things
through the perspective of the poor I
think that at some points it quits being
theology and becomes more just you know
taking taking Pharaoh you know basically
orthodox Marxist perspectives and
gusting them up with some theological
language but that's sort of at the
extreme I think there's there's usually
things to learn from it all right to do
[Music]
let's see here
Waldemar do I enjoy answering questions
unswervingly I'm not sure what
unswervingly means if you mean like in
order or without you know like setting
some aside I don't always do that in
part because the interface on the side
sometimes like skips up and down and you
know I'm looking at all these questions
and sometimes I I wind up skipping older
people I've also done the thing where if
one person asks a question I try to move
on to other people's questions before
coming back to theirs because otherwise
I'd get this string of like people
asking three four questions in a row I'm
trying to stack the deck on their side
but yeah I enjoy answering these these
questions okay so here's a follow-up of
the companions and Guilds argument says
if we reject moral realism we will also
have to reject realism about its
companions that is epistemic norms but
this is unacceptable so we must retain
moral realism holy crap is that abstract
I mean we put so much I could be put in
so much better terms and certainly has
by the classic authors you know I mean
and that just just shows me how in many
respects bankrupt contemporary analytic
ethics really is alright um let's see
volge Tech I think I have a surface
knowledge of the most important
philosophers and their ideas but I never
read any philosophical book could you
recommend me something to start with
yeah right well I always I always
suggest to start with Plato
I think Plato is great and you know
sooner or later you should you should
read him because he's always going to be
worth checking out so I would you know
get yourself copying Latos dialogues you
know they're reading some of the
dialogue I've got you know self direct
study video specifically on Plato so I
give you kind of a suggestion about you
know which dialogues to start with I
mean I wouldn't say let's let's start
you off with the Parmenides cuz I'm
never gonna come back to Plato again
you know but yeah you know that's that's
a good place to start I think all right
Anthony Fikri what are your thumb
bearing an analytic philosophy of
religion I've read some Swinburne I've
never found him particularly interesting
and that's an important category for me
as a philosopher in part because you
know I'm now at the point where probably
I've passed the halfway point of my life
you know I'm gonna be 49 and it's the
10th so I'm gonna be 49 and 8 days so I
you know when I read stuff I'm like is
this worth reading again is this worth
engaging with and I you know I think
that a lot of the stuff that analytic
philosophy of religion does is usually
poorly informed by historical work I
mean there's an entire you know two
millennia of thought on these matters
and and most of the I'm gonna generalize
here mostly analytic philosophers of
religion that I've met and interacted
with very poorly read people and some of
them don't like to read you know I
remember one where he was it was in a
facebook conversation it was stuff about
free will and I was like well you know
and some talks about that in the de
Libertad a and he was like which which
sections and I was like you lazy [ __ ]
why don't you just read the the friggin
book you know what's it gonna cost you
it's like you know this this thick why
wouldn't you you know want to read that
and then read everything else that
handsome has you could actually do it
within a matter of like a couple weeks
you know but a lot of analytic
philosophers just you know they do this
reinventing the wheel thing and I mean
there are some great exceptions John
wisdom some you know some of these
really people in analytic philosophy
really quite good you know John wisdom
believe it or not Alistair McIntyre in
Anthony fluo that's nice
you know you know thing on analytic
philosophy and religion from from early
on but the contemporary stuff you know
it's it's it's so discos
ciated from what it is that religion
actually looks like in the wild and the
whole tradition of you know
philosophical engagements with religion
going back all the way to the to the
ancient Greeks that it's just not worth
my time and it's probably not worth your
time either I mean there's a lot of
people out there in the field and you
can do that but I mean why why would you
want to read Swinburne when instead you
could spend your time reading Aquinas or
Anselm abui theists or or David Hume you
know or somebody who's much more
interesting all right Peter
notwithstanding the philosophical
narrative was Socrates trial a show
trial or its result predetermined well
it was predetermined once Socrates
decided he was gonna do what he was
going to do that if he could have
pleaded you know he could have managed
things in such a way as to not get
himself in trouble you know he could
have avoided the death penalty he chose
not to I don't think it was a show trial
at all I think I think it was you know
it was you know there were plenty of
people who were ticked off at Socrates
he acknowledges that mellitus Anytus you
know the other people who are bringing
up charges are young people who are
there to try to make a name for
themselves that wasn't the only one that
that happened like that but no I don't
think it's a show trial at all all right
Chris as I'm going to start a second
bachelor's degree in suing in philosophy
will the admissions for grad school just
see my performance in philosophy I'm not
sure what that's actually asking oh I
see I see so you're gonna you you want
to go on and do a third degree in
philosophy through grad school masters
or a PhD totally depends on the place
you don't want to really generalize
about how grad schools operate ask
somebody who's there ask like the
department SEC
Terry and they will be able to tell you
what goes on they may be called the
administrative assistant to the chair or
something like that they're gonna be the
person who actually knows what's what so
I would I would check in with that
alright um Stacy says okay there's more
of a comment I'm still here listening
and learning despite weather issues out
here in the brightness of the
Midsummer's like this Sun continued okay
I will Ryan asked there's the
Scientology of any place in
philosophical discourse you know it's
interesting I first encountered
Scientology when I picked up that book
Dianetics as I was getting on the plane
in the Saint Louis Airport to go to
Germany when I was you know in between
my basic and AIT training and my
permanent duty station in the army and I
was reading it on the plane and I was
like okay engrams okay I get what that
is because that's coming out of you know
like this old psychological theory and
the more that I read the more I was like
man this is this is some you know well
worded but crazy stuff I mean you could
you could certainly do an examination of
of Scientology if you're talking about
the literature of Scientology you could
certainly do an examination of that you
could certainly do like an examination
of their behavior and their assertions I
used to cover them pretty routinely when
we would do religion and American
culture and Parkers are an important
group but you know they're pretty far
out on the fringe and you know they also
go after their critics pretty pretty
much differently so they can be
classified as a cult they don't like
that of course but you know so they can
be used as an interesting example I
don't think that philosophically they
have anything to contribute you know so
if that's what we're talking about the
difference between being like a
tradition of philosophy and then being
just an object of philosophical
investigation
um Artie Whitby did Aristotle make
sufficient changes to the golden mean
and rhetoric to say that he created it
reinvented them or did he just improve
popularize the concepts which already
existed
Aristotle came up with the concept of
the mean I mean this golden mean
[ __ ] put that aside you know there
are things like you know there were
Delphic Maxim's like not too much and
all that Aristotle's the guy comes up
with the doctrine of the mean in Western
philosophy so this whole like you know
trait trying to trace it back further
that's just wishful thinking I know that
there's a Wikipedia entry out there on
it but there's Wikipedia entries on all
sorts of stuff rhetoric Aristotle was a
contemporary of my Socrates who at a
school of rhetoric
there's Aristotle is not the only guy
doing rhetoric at the time and you can
say that he's different from a
philosophical point of view and that he
reevaluate Surete Uruk is something that
can be positive but he also realizes
that a lot of rhetoric is garbage and
just trying to appeal to the emotions he
actually talks about he coins the term
technology and talking about the
technical logo those were the people who
write rhetoric textbooks which are
basically how to push people's emotional
buttons at the time so I would I would
be very leery of worrying about sort of
big picture history of ideas stuff that
that you know doesn't get a little bit
more granular about both those sorts of
things
mr. despair is pop irrelevant in this
day and age yeah I mean he's worth he's
worth checking out in terms of like you
know falsification stuff that's
interesting I mean I think that his
takes on classic philosophical figures
are garbage you know in the open society
and its enemies but you know people want
to read that stuff go on ahead so do you
need popper necessarily to get the
falsification thing I don't think so but
you know
all right one two three lay low one two
three about veganism what is true of an
animal that if true of a human being
would justify killing and eating the
human for food let me see if I can
figure out what's actually being asked
there what it would animals and humans
have in common that would justify I
think quite frankly that if we were in
some sort of disaster situation and
there were dead humans around I wouldn't
have a problem with eating them if there
wasn't any other food but I'm you know
not particularly squeamish in that way
and you know quite frankly if I was dead
I'm looking over at my cat right now and
my corpse was what was left I wouldn't
care she ate me
you know I'd be quite happy that she was
able to survive longer on doing that but
I think what you have in mind is you're
trying to make sort of a polemical point
that well you know how are animals and
humans so different that would justify
us you know it's okay for us to kill
pigs and make them into bacon but we
don't do that to you know people and you
know generally somebody always has
somebody let's do that to the rich we
would do that to the poor I think that
we can easily say that the modes of
farming that are being done now factory
farming are unethical without saying
that all killing and eating of animals
is therefore an unethical you know I
mean we can indeed live on on
plant-based diets when things are going
really really well I know that you know
I know doctors for example who have
patients who are vegans ethical vegans
and they get sick and they'll say listen
I respect your point of view but you got
to eat some chicken soup you got it you
got to eat some yogurt you got it you
know do some of these things I think
when it comes to this we want to be more
realistic and less extreme when it comes
to these matters we should minimize our
meat consumption most likely in some
cases we should we should eliminate
and we should eliminate factory farming
but that doesn't mean that we should
totally eliminate you know animal
products and that's that's what vegans
generally start from so alright Diogenes
a cynic what do I make of Melanie Klein
a good person to read you know fits into
that that psychoanalytic tradition you
know my mentor
Garth Gillen was really quite interested
in her and I know that you know when I
did the seminar with MacIntyre on
rational choice Theory Aristotelian
tullman ISM and the psychoanalytic
tradition Klein was one of the people
that he was also looking to as well in
addition to Freud Lacan Winnicott and
also Anna Freud and people like that
so she's worth she's worth checking out
t go arou Joe's asking about Graham
Harman and object-oriented anthologies
also stuff I've talked about plenty of
times in the past I met Graham harmony
interacted with them maybe I'm missing
something I don't really find it all
that that interesting but you know there
we go
you sonís asked about yet for Hegel I
answered that earlier and the thing is
my schedule been too packed and the past
months to continue it yeah I mentioned I
thought you know thirteen classes from
fall 2018 to to summer 2019 I'm still
teaching one of my classes right now
this semester I'm teaching seven classes
for four different universities and I've
turned down an additional six classes at
other places that that's how in demand I
am as a teacher so that takes quite a
bit of time away from from Hegel topos
actually depression is more present in
wealthy people I mean how do we actually
know you know these generalizations like
that are quite funny because when you
dig into them and start looking at the
study designs maybe it maybe it means
that maybe it doesn't I know plenty of
poor people who are depressed as hell's
matter of fact
about there's an entire encampment of
many of them living just four blocks
from here a tent city that we have here
at Milwaukee there's all different kinds
of ways of being depressed in all
different ways at all different modes of
that so I wouldn't make generalizations
like that
Martin Costa what's your opinion on
George's Bataille and his influence on
French postmodernists I don't think he
has a lot of influence on French
postmodernist quite quite frankly at
this point I think that he did get them
you know more interested in Nietzsche
and Hegel but I don't think that there's
the tie is kind of undervalued stock I
actually like to tie quite a lot and
it's also it in part cause he doesn't
fit neatly into two packages or
classifications that said it's been
several years since I had a chance to
read him so I can't say too much about
him right now but he's a fun guy to to
read let's see here arty Whitby is the
influence of Platonism stronger the New
Testament or the Old Testament neither
there's an inch once of platonism again
you gotta avoid this like big picture
like there's like this strain and this
strain and this strain kind of history
of ideas because that that stuff is just
usually garbage I know that it's quite
popular in the text books and it was
really popular in the 19th and early
20th century but man that's uh you know
where you will find interesting
influences would would be like in say
fourth Maccabees or stoicism isn't it
but that's that's a non canonical work
you know it's not part of the Testaments
these things are always way more
complicated than than that let's see
robert says as a question he sings about
a hard time understanding where he's
getting in with ground and the principle
of sufficient reason it's been a while
since I've been reading that so I don't
have much much helpful you know in this
format to say about that I'd have to go
back to the essay and I'd also have to
talk to you about what what it is that
you're you're finding difficult with it
alright we got a bunch of other things
Dan cranek nice to see you here
long time no no see he's one of the guys
who came out to one of my talks from a
couple states over a long time ago do
have any general methods or things to
keep in mind when it comes to presenting
philosophy to a general audience that's
a good question I gave such a talk this
week I appreciate but ya gonna be yeah
boy there's a lot that could be said
about that one is you don't have to
think of it as like you know or a
practice that is dumbing things down a
general audience you know if they're
coming out to a talk on philosophy
they're not dumb people they may not
have had a you know a background that
gave them introduction to all the
terminology and where the pieces fit and
stuff like that but if you as an
interpreter and that's how you should
think of yourself you're interpreting
whatever it is that you're talking about
for somebody else just like it is if you
are hired to interpret you know for a
business conference
you're trying to put things into words
that that other people can easily
understand and you also want to make
sure you use examples that they can
relate to this is a big problem by the
way an analytic in an academic
philosophy where you know we still have
instructors like my age and a little bit
younger trying to use pop-culture
references that our students just are
not going to get you know and if you
insist that they somehow get them well
you better do a lot of explaining and it
better somehow connect to their life
experience or else it's not it's going
to be seen as self-indulgent it's not
going to help them and that's another
thing too you should think of yourself
as you're there too
your audience understand something that
they they are interested in so you know
like if you think about the talks that I
do anger where I'm bringing in you know
different philosophical theories from
ancient and medieval philosophy you want
to find contemporary examples and you
want to be able to frame it in
contemporary terms so through the most
the most is the part of us that gets
riled up right that that word riled up
that's not there in Plato but it's
certainly worth using because we can
relate to it pretty easily the other
thing I'd say too is when it comes to
talking to a general audience and I'm
not I'm not very good at following this
rule but less is more right you can
always give them like a one-page sheet
that has like where to get additional
resources on this stuff and not try to
provide at all in the talk and overwhelm
people I'm not particularly good at
doing that on myself so oh wow
so me a buyer please please please
please please please talk about the
Duino elegies I've listened to all your
really acts and you said you would one
day yeah well that that that's an
undertaking I would like to do that I
would like to do that when I can say
that I've sufficiently wrapped my head
around how this works
I mean they are really they're they're
wonderful and they're metaphysical and
yeah there's a lot going on in that but
I will say that I will do them
eventually this this semester
unfortunately I'm mostly shooting
content for my classes so I'm you know
like I'm teaching I've taught it in the
past but I need videos and I'm teaching
like Mills on Liberty you know I got to
shoot the videos for the rest of the
Descartes meditation is four through six
and stuff like that so that's that's
going to take up a lot of my time but
maybe maybe this coming year
uh Carabas at sea and thoughts on Rousso
and me'll that's a long book to get
through that's one that's number one
thought was so I like reading Rousseau
better when in just reading his like
straight-out philosophical social stuff
so yeah I think that's probably I mean
and I don't buy into his educational
psychology so mr. disappear what's your
most unpopular opinion on philosophy
that kind of thing you find yourself to
create disagreeing sell them with people
my most unpopular opinion on philosophy
I don't know that's a tough one to come
up with I say quite a few things when
I'm like in in sessions like this and
I'm not just doing you know core concept
videos where I'm presenting somebody
else's thing that that probably pissed
people off I mean I guess here's here's
something that would probably be one of
my most unpopular opinions most of the
political forces out there right now in
America are actually not concerned with
the common good and are damaging to our
well what there is left of our democracy
and at the same time the Republicans
have metastasized into something
cancerous to our democracy and the
Democrats are not as bad so it's it's
worth even knowing that that many of
them are you know machine Democrats or
what you call establishment Democrats or
that some of them are you know really
far left loonies it's worth voting for
them this this time around
that's probably an unpopular opinion all
right do I have any suggestions for
starting to learn global history or
history in general any particular books
um global history or history in general
I mean I I don't I don't have any
suggestions that are gonna be
particularly good because I'm not I'm
not out there reading sort of general
world history books so I don't really I
don't know the field too well but I
think part of what you want to do is so
you want to read some stuff that is like
sort of what's going on within the world
and in particular areas but you also
want to find good stuff that specializes
in particular let's call them
civilizations and cultures so this is
going to be very very broad big-picture
stuff you can say that throughout
history there have been some let's call
them culture areas or civilization areas
that have been predominant and this has
been in part because of you know
military power and cultural power but
also because of economic networks and
exploration and stuff like that and you
can talk about the West right and the
west ends up colonizing the Americas and
Australia and places like that as well
and that's you know that's worth
studying but you want a narrative that
that doesn't just make it all about you
know the spread of the European you want
one that's equally attentive to the
importance of China and the whole
Chinese culture sphere which includes
other countries and and people's
influenced by them running from you know
Korea and Japan all the way down into
Southeast Asia I mean the spread of the
Chinese you know globally there's over
100 million overseas Chinese the Indian
cultural sphere what was at one time
called Greater India
and you want to be attentive to you know
the what was going on within Islam I
can't actually recommend one one book
about that that's about you know this
thick it's really quite good at least I
found it quite good I think it's called
the history of Islamic civilization by
IRA Lapidus I always found that quite a
useful resource and then you know you do
all you do also want to think about
other civilizations as well you know
those in Africa some of the great
civilizations that arose within the
Americas and then you want to think
about how these these connected up with
each other and and you know you can
definitely point out some people who are
bad guys but there's nobody who's really
a you know really good guy you know
across the board when it comes to
geopolitics so that might be enough all
right let's see who else we've got just
go with it have you read much of her in
a Garrard how much do you feel he's
undervalued as a thinker yeah I read a
good bit of him back when I was in
graduate school and he is undervalued as
a thinker I think his idea mimetic
desire you know he's not the only person
to note that but it's really quite quite
a brilliant insight and I like I like
Rene Girard I think he's quite quite
good I get a plug my computer and it
looks like it wasn't plugged in there we
go I would you know I would say that
he's worth reading sort of like the tie
you know a lot of people you know when
they think about continental philosophy
they're like I you know i I've read a
little bit of Derrida and Foucault in
Toulouse and there's all these other
really cool figures that that are not as
often brought up and are often much more
interesting like Gerard and bataille
attend Maurice merleau-ponty is somebody
else's can
like that too well worth reading and
often undervalued Miguel will I vote for
Bernie Sanders I guess you know if he's
the Democratic candidate probably so
because I'm definitely not voting for
Trump I mean we'll see what it'll be
we're a battleground state here in
Wisconsin and we will have our primary
coming up next year so we'll see how
many people actually make it into the
ballot for the primary all right me a
buyer has a very nice nice thing she
stood there I go free Keller what was
the most big what was the biggest impact
mock Schaller left and hiding her in
terms of philosophy I don't think that
Schaller actually left that much of an
impact on Heidegger I think that you
know Heidegger mentions him but I don't
think he learned that much from Schaller
and he thinks that shale errs basic
approach is fundamentally wrong but
that's because Heidegger thinks that
fundamental ontology is the way to go I
actually like Schaller a lot I think
he's you know quite quite worth reading
at one time I I translated almost all of
your tetanus and our bite never ended up
doing anything with it and then a friend
of mine later on well more of a
colleague actually he could I guess he
quit being a friend because we didn't
really stay in contact ended up
publishing it and he wanted to see mine
is sort of cross comparison so I thought
Schrader was well worth worth studying
I'm not sure how to pronounce the relic
letters so I'm not I'm not going to try
to pronounce this person's name but why
did analytical philosophy become
predominant in the english-speaking
world why is this tradition to giving
more popular the rest of the world where
other traditions are losing popularity
that's a good question
two questions so analytic philosophy
became popular in the english-speaking
world because they they did two things
one was they just basically discarded
the past except for mining it for
occasional things and said that it was
worthless and you shouldn't bother you
know studying it and then the other
thing is they did a fairly aggressive
campaign of taking over institutions and
journals and eventually classical
American philosophy sort of went by the
wayside
there was a vibrant you know you know
well well engaged with the past Catholic
philosophy mostly associated with tomé
ISM that they'd totally ignored
continental philosophy which by the way
got here to the United States largely
through Catholic institutions like Ford
you know places like that they tried to
lock that out as much as possible and
they they're really engaged in for a
couple generations now philosophical
imperialism now they don't do that quite
so much in part because the analytic
philosophy is in such a mess itself
they've got all these different
discourses none of which really
communicate effectively with each other
they some of them realize just how badly
off they are by not engaging with with
the history of philosophy or other other
fields and you know it becomes dominant
in other areas because people like stuff
that seems to be simpler and doesn't
have as big of an investment you learn
you learn a discourse instead of
learning a broad discourse but it isn't
it isn't necessarily like taking over
and in everywhere where right I mean as
far as I know although there are
analytic philosophers in Germany and
there are you know continental
philosophers like Habermas or Paul
record who's long gone that was in
France do engage with analytic
philosophy it's not like vomit it's
force you know and when it does become
the dominant force it's usually because
whatever is being done locally is is
kind of you know it's become kind of
abstruse and not particularly helpful
but the antidote for that is doing
history of philosophy are doing you know
continental philosophy better not just
bringing in a bunch of analytics hey so
uh all right
Thabo thoughts on Quine at worth reading
I mean what else what else are you gonna
say it's part of the history of analytic
philosophy has got some interesting
things to say sort of you know
fundamentally off-base and is
fundamental project but you know okay it
doesn't mean he's not interesting
aesthetics thoughts on Nikola Tesla no
spirituality I don't really know much
about Nikola Tesla and his spirituality
so I don't have anything useful to say
about that nom sky reading Camus was a
rebel could you suggest any other
material related to rebellion from
possibly different perspectives
well Hana Arendt has a whole work on on
that what else comes to mind
I mean rebellion itself
I don't know nothing else like pops like
top of mind but I'm sure you know
quicksearch would find all sorts of
interesting things all right
nassim what do I think about gender
critical feminists aka Turks in academia
and in general so I'll say two things
one is that as a academic and as a you
know heterosexual white male middle-aged
when it comes to like the wars between
gender critical feminists and trans
activists and and all these different
things like played out and had patient's
at we philosophers better like get
involved in it I'm not touching that
stuff with a ten-foot pole because I
know that whatever position I take
somebody is going to be pissed off with
me and it's you know I've got stuff to
do
it's not worth my my time and attention
to sort of squander it on discourses
that other people are going to be doing
particularly when there's sort of
entrance cards to get it you know the
best I can be is classified as an ally
and you can go from being a lie to go
like that for both sides right so this
is a highly charged thing so that's it
the other thing I'll say is it you know
looking at it play out like on Twitter
for example it seems to me that a lot of
the people who call themselves gender
critical feminists really are just try
and use it to exclude trans people I
think that I mean it's really quite
interesting to see what's happening
right so we talk in terms of like the
LGBTQ and then you can add in whatever
else you want spectrum and we talk about
it as if it's like a monolithic thing
just that there's difference there and
then there's like the people who are
opposed to that over here and you know
there are there are very different ways
of being gay for example and not all of
them look at and say trans activism and
pushing for trans rights and stuff like
that in a positive way same thing with
with lesbians and by the way I think
it's when it when it comes down to
things like you know trans women saying
you know you have to accept me and that
means like being being willing to be
attracted to me even though I have you
know male equipment I'm still a woman
I think that that you know lesbians are
perfectly legitimate and saying yet not
my thing buddy
and I'm not going to call you a woman
because of that you know if you're gonna
push that hard so there I think there's
a lot of bad actors on both sides in
this sort of thing and a lot of people
kind of sorting things out and it's
really just a mess
I myself you know have quite a few
friends family members colleagues who
fit into that whole spectrum in one way
or another and I sure as hell don't want
to see them being forced into situations
where they can't exercise basic rights
you know something for example is you
know the whole bathroom issue you know
there's a lot of trans people who just
don't go to the bathroom and that has
health effects and the fact that we're
at the point where people are like
worked up about that sort of stuff just
shows how stupid so many people are
stupid and bigoted and you know you got
to ask the people who are super invested
yeah like you know policing all of this
why is it such an issue and we have so
many other bigger issues like I
mentioned there's a tent city just four
blocks from here of homeless people in
Milwaukee that probably you know that's
probably more of an issue I mean the
mayor actually went after Marquette
University because the Marquette bought
a hotel that's right across from that
that's that's you know closed
why isn't Marquette housing those people
there I think that's probably a bigger
issue than who's peeing and what stall
you know but like I said I'm sure
somebody's gonna you know construe this
in some way that's that's you know bad
it's a super messy issue and I'm not I'm
not gonna myself get involved in it
while it's so fluid you know other than
supporting the people that I know that
who are are trans to include some of my
students Joe alright um mister despair
what am i reading right now well I
mentioned it earlier my guilty pleasure
reading is Carl Edward Wagner's Kane
novels is a nice map inside I first
bought my
my first cane novel well actually it's a
set of stories connected together called
Death Angel shadow when I was about nine
or ten I remember I took it along on a
boating trip that we did when my dad was
still alive and I was like Carl Edward
and his character cane so that's the
guilty pleasure reading all right herb
or ace have you ever read Herman
Phillips he's got in the Age of Reason
from 2012 nope I haven't read it's Jacob
Barrett what are the most important
philosophers for Christians to read same
canon as everybody else you know all
these great philosophers throughout
history some of whom were Christians
some of whom were not so I'm a little
more anti Christians you should read
them all because you know it's it's
smart to to know the background coppa
mul mondo can we expect videos on dari
de Fuko Baudrillard are you not a fan of
postmodern philosophers
I haven't wrote my dissertation on dari
guy you know and I like Foucault and I
like baudrillard I'm not as big of a fan
I don't but I've I've published on them
in the past you know right now I'm like
I said I'm shooting stuff for my classes
I'm not teaching postmodern stuff in my
classes because we barely have enough
time to get through the history of
philosophy stuff but I think it's
important for students to encounter but
yeah down down the line I probably
certainly will
Vedran have you read any of Bertrand
Russell's texts any of Chomsky's yeah I
read Chomsky's stuff on linguistics when
I was interested in philosophy of
language and I read Russell quite a lot
in undergraduate and graduate school
Chomsky's linguistic stuff I don't
really buy into too much Russell is not
a good historian of philosophy so I
highly recommend his history of
philosophy as a source
I was really fun it's a fun read
so if you like that that's that's cool
but then you may as well also read
William Durant's history or story of
philosophy which is about at the same
level but you know Russell was involved
with this whole low justice project
which is quite important for early
analytic philosophy and interesting and
its own respect all right so any
existential philosophy text of the mind
body condition yeah starts being a
nothingness I mean books this thick it
talks a lot about all those sorts of
issues and about freedom and determinism
and about you know how we perceive and
about all sorts of other things so yeah
there's plenty of things you could find
I'm do live I heard the news about Jeff
Epstein how could I not hear it you know
I'm on Twitter's oh you know Twitter is
is full of it I don't I don't you know I
don't know enough about the situation to
actually have any any comment so I'm not
gonna like add to the conspiracy fuel
that that's currently out there oh okay
here we go
Borough room any plans to return to lead
chef stoves apotheosis of groundlessness
slash all things are possible yeah
eventually I would and I'd also like to
do some stuff on some of chefs Don's
other works you know he's got this
really nice book on Dostoevsky in a
Nietzsche from early in his career and
then of course later on Athens and
Jerusalem but I'm not teaching him in
classes including even when I teach
existentialism cuz I don't get enough
time so it'll be a while before it
before I do that John Ortiz have your
views about getting a philosophy degree
change given that the job market is not
so good and what do I think about PhD
programs offer certifications such as
psych well you know you're talking about
my video on getting a philosophy degree
this job situation was crap back then
too right so that's not changed yeah as
matter of fact if anything it's got a
little bit better I think that you know
it it's something that I saw this back
then if you really really want a
philosophy degree sure go ahead and get
it there's other things you can do with
a philosophy degree other than being a
professor and that's that's a smart
thing to do this ties in with that
getting a certification yeah you can get
a certification you can do a lot of
other stuff to to make sure that you
actually have jobs lined up if you're
gonna do philosophy the one thing you
don't want to do is just narrowly
specialize in some little sub feel the
philosophy without explaining to the
general public why what you do is
important but you know if you're going
to get into if you're gonna do a
philosophy degree program with the idea
that you're going to become a philosophy
professor you're probably screwing
yourself because there's not a lot of
professor jobs out there and they go to
the people who come from the top-tier
universities and to go to a top-tier
University generally you need some
polling you need some money or you want
or you'll take out some big you know
student loans or you know if you can max
out the GRE or something like that you
might get in as well but most of the
most of the people in these these elite
programs they're from academic families
and they you know they're people who may
have struggled in their life but they're
usually you know middle-class on up it
wouldn't occur to many of us to even go
to go to those those programs when I was
in school all right Linda nice to see
you I struggle a bit with Hegel's idea
that knowledge can be brought into
consciousness as object since it's so
distinct from the physical world even
though it's about the world well I mean
if you're if you're thinking about if
you go all the way back to like you know
Plato and Aristotle you think of
questions about what what is knowledge
is it something that's like and I'm
gonna use like our head is a container
you know where the form of the thing you
know either we're connected with the
ideal form like Plato says the pattern
or you know somehow we've got like an
image of the form
the individual thing and its its species
the way Aristotle thinks we can we can
bring that in into our minds and we can
you know we can think of or we can bring
that into our purview and we can think
about propositions it starts to get kind
of messy and dicey when it starts to get
closer to the real world but I think you
know we can bring it into consciousness
it's not something we can do immediately
I think right and part of what Hegel
says over and over again is immediacy is
just the starting point you know
whatever we're beginning with is not
like the full picture and we develop it
outward from there all right PPP asks
about an activism and constructivism of
Varela matura of on Forrester I don't
know you know that's that's not if it's
influential in modern cognitive science
good for them it's not that's something
that I really spent any time on so I
don't have much to say about it
today my Francisco Varela though I did
translate part of one of his works at
one point in time on being aware but I
don't know what the cog side people are
doing spedex thoughts on blockchain
cryptocurrency and artificial
intelligence I think those are you know
blockchain and cryptocurrency that's
over here artificial intelligence that's
a whole different thing over here
that's that's my thoughts on that all
right let's see here
ask what's my views about the Kashmir
issue that I don't know enough about to
actually say I'd been trying to find out
more but you know you there's you're not
getting a lot of information coming out
of there so I'm not going to say too
much about that other than the fact that
you know it's Modi's India right so all
right Nathan Orman speaking on the
street I guess that's maybe a podcast or
something had a social cut
constructivist meta ethic how would you
deal with it no idea I'd probably deal
with it in the same plant but dealing
with it at the present you know all
right let's see here that just skipped
for a while there's some guy who's just
posting over and over again
swearing I'll see if I can't get rid of
him all right
the interface isn't working quite as
good as it should
okay do I have any lectures this is from
Berkeley on Hegel's idea of history I
mean I touch on in the half hour Hegel
lecture stuff but no I don't have a
lecture specifically on that TK asks if
I have a favorite Democratic candidate
no I don't
all of them have problems there isn't
any like perfect candidate out there I'm
waiting to see what they're they're
willing to do but I am NOT a Democrat so
you know mister disappear how long did
it take me to get Hegel I I would say
that that's an ongoing process when I go
to shoot a half-hour Hegel video there's
you know I did a video specifically on
how I do the videos there's way more
time reading and thinking than the
actual shooting and editing that goes on
canal what do I make of Adorno's
negative dialectics one of my first
publications was on Adorno's negative
dialectics
so obviously I'm a fan but Adorno is
somebody very difficult to use the
Ronald Adorno I was like hey low level
complexity I would say Lyndon do I
consider the marquis de sade be a
philosopher or a man of letters or
neither he's a philosopher he's just not
a very good one you know and he
basically has a two-track mind when you
read mark the Marquis de Sade's novels
they are very boring
I remember reading them because I you
know I'd heard about this this you know
racy guy and how how much sex was going
on in his novels and he makes sex boring
you know he he just it's all these
different combinations of this net so
then that's this guy's whipping this
person who's screwing this person who's
saying this the only really interesting
stuff
it has novels are the dialogue yeah
and there you know it's people basically
talking him he's a he's an Enlightenment
figures using enlightenment thought
turning it on its head and then you know
it's kind of interesting but he's not a
great philosopher I would say die a
Janine's why do you not value to lose
that much only curious because I'm
really enjoying anti Oedipus well auntie
Oedipus is not to lose anti Oedipus is
delusion guitar e and I actually think
that to lose does way better work when
he's on his own than when he's with
Qatari I I like some of the losses stuff
I've mentioned this many many times
I really like the essays critical and
clinical I like the logic of sense I
like that sort of stuff
auntie Oedipus I think it was you know
kind of overrated so yeah all right it's
your Gabriel how can one live by
Nietzsche's philosophy well pick the
parts that work for you and leave out
the rest because I think you're gonna
have a hard time living with it
otherwise right so yeah that that
probably is enough to say about that
doesn't look like some of the features
in in this interface work as well as
they should all right
Cramer's asks what is my view on jean
baudrillard and baudrillard is an
interesting person I first encountered
in a grad school and I you know I liked
his his stuff he you know there's the
notion of the hyperreal I think is a
real contribution I think it's better if
we put it in terms of other other you
know theories we could say right but it
is it is really interesting stuff so all
right let's see what we got this this
person took up a lot of space in here
doing stuff that's hidden um but I can't
deliver ah okay Tyler says my lectures
and Aristotle been very helpful things
for my work yeah you're welcome
there's a lot of Aristotle that I
haven't gotten to I really would like to
get to and we'll see when I am ever able
to to really do it so yeah all right
here we go Bradford grass speaking of
undervalued philosophers who's the
Spanish philosopher you'd consider most
important to read so I'm not very
well-read in in in Spanish or Iberia and
philosophy in general so I'm not really
a good person to ask about that I've
only read a few Spanish philosophers but
I do like Miguel de Unamuno he's
considered one of the early
existentialists he doesn't he's often
like written off as just being a poet or
essayist but I think he's a good
philosopher I mean if Pascal's a
philosopher I think would a Munoz a
philosopher so he's worth reading and
then of course you know we do have our
Spanish American philosopher George
Santayana right so maybe we consider him
we could put him in there as well let's
see here
Proform any advice on reaching past
people's preconceived ideas on important
ideas political intellectual otherwise
that's very tough to do I would say that
at this point in time like here in
America things are so polarized
especially on the right but also on the
left but even more so on the right where
people like bought you know drunk the
kool-aid I mean if you're if you're a
conservative Catholic or an evangelical
and you somehow think that you know
Trump is not just not a bad guy but
actually is somehow like you know a
savior figure you're unreachable and
it's sad to see but that's that's the
case the only thing that will change
people's minds in cases like that is
somehow being betrayed by the figures
who they they they idolize and even then
they'll often like a dog who's been you
know beaten returned back and so there's
not much you can do
in that case there's a lot of other
people who have been traumatized in
other ways as well and have you know
some sort of essentially you know the
enemies set up the people that are
reachable are reachable not primarily
through like providing the best
arguments at this time and they're not
they're not reachable through propaganda
either they're reachable through genuine
engagement which means unfortunately
being vulnerable to them and reaching
out to them over and over and over again
and not arguing with them all the time
and living with them despite the fact
that a lot of them are [ __ ] and
they're [ __ ] because of what they've
taken on you know and that's that's just
what you got to do and you got to be
okay with the fact that you're you're
gonna find many people not particularly
reachable or only reachable after
investing a lot of time but you know we
just keep on keep on working at it so
all right
phantom upload do I think that Achilles
and Patroclus had a romantic
relationship in the Iliad yeah of course
they did they were lovers
who thinks they weren't I mean the
ancient literature is really clear on
that
Liberty Atlas sewer I think you should
state your opinion no academics speak
out academics speak out all the time I
don't I don't know where that's coming
from just go on Twitter and you'll see
lots of people speaking out all right
let's see here ah it's it soon Ibaka one
of my friends is anti philosophical are
very skeptical of it I try to avoid
discussing issues within but they're
unavoidable as philosophy is how do I
approach these issues with them so you
know if you if you mean like the person
is dismissing philosophies of discipline
you're you're not gonna reach them other
than overtime you know try to avoid
discussing issues with them but they're
unavoidable
you don't always call philosophy
philosophy you know when I when I do
corporate training and it's like an
anger management or something like that
I don't tell them that the ideas are
coming from Aristotle and Thomas Aquinas
because that would turn them off I say I
present the ideas and then if they want
to know where they came from I say well
there's where they come from and you
know if they say this sounds like
emotional intelligence stuff I could say
something like well you know what's the
first quote in emotion in the book
emotional intelligence and they say I
don't know well it's a quote from
Aristotle and then that that's opens the
ground but I don't think that it uh I
don't think that a lot of these people
are reachable in a direct way ash do I
think Christianity helped with the rise
of science Christianity is such I'm not
even sure what Christianity big-picture
word abstraction is I know that
Christians are certainly contributed to
the rise of science a lot of the people
doing work were religious many of them
clergy so Zach McQuillen how easy it is
it to just jump into Vidkun schneid well
that's a good question I didn't find it
too difficult myself because that's what
I did as an undergraduate but I was
really interested in language already
and so you got to be really interested
in language to read vintage type I'll
tell you that
right because that's all that that's all
that is really going to talk about over
and over and over again there will be a
few other things as well but they're all
going to be connected with language just
so long as you don't expect it to be
like whatever else you've studied in
philosophy you're probably going to be
okay
[Music]
all right let's see here it just skipped
a bit more here we go
John is advice on when to choose to read
the text when you generally prefer
audiobooks when available even been
listening to PDFs using a program on my
phone
well I mean different people consume
texts in different ways if you really
like audiobooks I don't see anything
wrong with that you knew you do
appropriate text I know this from
experience like listening to audiobooks
of the books that I've already read in
other you know in text format when I
would like do a lot of long-distance
driving I'd have books on CD you you
hear things there you you interpret the
information differently right sometimes
it's good to have both I would say so
yeah how would our conception of Western
philosophy if we found new philosophical
thought that could be traced to
Mycenaean Greece it was just as complex
and in-depth as Aristotelian philosophy
we'd have a lot of rethinking to do I
don't I don't know how I would rethink
it but I mean you're sort of like that's
that's a pretty improbable idea given
what we know about the cultural
development at the time I don't know I
don't know how it would change in you
know the you know the big picture stuff
so alright Jeremy asked thoughts on kg
nishitani z-- religion and nothingness I
haven't read it so I don't have any
ideas on it
RK says I like German and French
philosophy more than the anglo-saxon
thinkers I find them deeper more radical
and less instrumental as there's some
truth in this opinion it depends on
which French and
thinkers and anglo-saxon thinkers you're
talking about doesn't it because you can
find superficial trivial people in every
every area can't you which ones are you
comparing against which ones I mean I
can think of some people who write in
English or I think are you know quite
profound some of whom are contemporaries
and some of whom are you know within the
last say 400 years him is well worth
reading even though I you know I think
he's wrong I got a lot of points are CLE
is certainly interesting
I wish you'd written more so I don't
know it depends on on which thing here
is you're thinking about I mean you can
find like a whole bunch of non entities
in German and French philosophy if you
look hard enough I'm not talking about
like the big picture thinkers big you
know figures that we often have but you
know you've got to like read around in
the sort of second tier of thinkers and
you'll you'll find that mediocrity can
be found anywhere alright Jay tunic was
Anselm Amano thelight I don't think so
not sure why you're there why are you
asking but let's see your Oh Noble I
come from a Muslim background that
shaped my identity how do I acknowledge
my heritage and respect it while
transcending it into free thinking
depends on you know what you kown is
free thinking you mean it's like being
an atheist because that's typically what
free thinkers mean you could a you know
you could continue to to do a lot of
things that are connected with Islam
because Islam is not just a religion but
you can also think of it I mentioned I
real a penis is
you know history of Islamic civilization
it's also tied in with all these these
civilizations or or cultures so you
could you could certainly preserve a lot
of that and like a lot of people who you
know left Christian churches or or you
know grew up Jewish and abandoned it
doesn't mean you have to like throw away
everything you could you know you can
take the things that you think are
valuable from moral precepts you know
practices and you know a great example
right praying five times a day so you
probably don't pray five times a day but
you could certainly be mindful of you
know our shared humanity five times a
day so there's all sorts of things that
you could you could bring in mr. big
week me how do you suggest introducing
young people to philosophy I suppose you
can't go wrong with an easy primary text
I mean there's a lot of different ways
there's like a whole discipline out
there of people and organizations that
are people who are like doing philosophy
for children and I don't do much of that
I mean I have kids and they know some
philosophical stuff but that that's in
part from talking with me and in part
because like you know they look things
up on YouTube and usually get the
drawing most of the users if isn't very
good but they're talking about
philosophical ideas you know there's
books out there you know that are
supposed to be philosophy oriented for
children I don't know I'm not a I'm not
a big fan of that stuff I I think you
could have a kid read some Plato or read
some other stuff and it would be good
for them I'd be challenging so J to Nick
will you ever do videos on Saint John of
Damascus I mean I've done a video that
talks a bit about John of Damascus it's
the one about Aristotle and the eight
tastes that was part of what spurred my
my research into that because I I was
you know I'd already read Aristotle
on the foal and stuff like that or yeah
there's that passage we talked about the
eight tastes but I haven't paid much
attention to it and then in John Demasi
--nz exposition of the Orthodox faith
there's this this section where he's
talking about the sense of taste and he
says as we know and although there are
these eight flavors and I was like wait
a second where did that come from
and I just traced it back and that sure
enough that came from Aristotle I
mentioned John Demasi and I think a
little bit in my presentation on through
most that I did at the Aristotle and
Aristotelian tradition conference this
summer at Marquette and yeah there was
that but I don't know I mean I'm not a
specialist I'm on him so all right let's
see it's a little we're a little bit
over time I'll see if we got here Zach
what do I think about Andrew Young and
universal basic income well young is an
interesting candidate because he's
coming in kind of from the outside of
the Democratic Party structure I think
giving people a thousand bucks for
universal basic income is not enough I
mean how would you live on that here in
Milwaukee that's that's like nothing you
know and you know there is this worry
that if we give people universal basic
income given the way other things work
people you know will be like oh well you
got the ubi I don't to pay much for the
work that I'm in can expect from you so
that there have to be some safeguards
against that but I actually think that
eventually we're probably going to have
to move to something like universal
basic income I anticipate within the
next twenty years that we're going to
have a lot more unemployment and I don't
you know I don't see anybody really
addressing that it's going to be a
serious issue
let's see what else I can take very
quickly and then I'll give you guys a
nice view out of the window but it's a
great question of them proform you work
very hard but seem to take good care of
yourself seem is the key thing there
right do you have any tips for finding a
balance for your work in self-care
whatever amount of here's the advice
because I do work very hard and I'm
trying to do things that are good for me
but I'm not doing quite enough whatever
you think you're doing for self-care you
probably couldn't should do more if
you're somebody like me right
here's somebody who's self-indulgent
well it's easy to you know do do more
and more self-care right but uh yeah
alright let me take this this question
from Travis what when people are
deliberately antagonistic towards me I
tend to dwell on it because I don't want
to respond angrily how do I let go of
resentment though that's that's a good
question you know there there are
various cognitive techniques that you
can find in psychotherapy and an ancient
philosophy that can help you do that
talking with somebody and not so much
just venting but figuring out why it is
that you feel the way that you do and
then thinking about your you know your
assumptions that can that can help to
defuse some of that as well just
stuffing it down not not really helpful
because you don't you know change things
that way and that creates a habit of
just sort of stuffing it down as well
there are there are always going to be
people antagonistic towards I mean you
know Marcus Aurelius chapter two of the
meditations where after he's done with
although thank you thank you stuff in
Chapter one he says basically you're
gonna meet a lot of [ __ ] today
remind yourself of this this and this
and this and he doesn't pull punches
saying you know you're gonna meet these
people who are jerks
they're in a it's not just that they're
they're you know they're slightly off
base or something like that no they're
jerks
so you know not responding angrily
that's probably a good thing but if it's
causing you resentment that's that's not
a good thing
wow I just got a text from from my my
wife who says I should call her when I'm
done with this event so I am going to
bring this to a close but before that
I'm gonna give you a little sight out of
the window of the City of Milwaukee from
where we live
nice day out today you can see the
steeples of you know Jesu and some of
the other churches the weird spaceship
looking thing that is Brewers Stadium
and that that hotel by the way that
you're seeing that massive structure
with the radio tower on top that's gonna
be full when the Democratic National
Convention comes here to Milwaukee next
summer we're gonna be living just a
block from where some of the activities
are taking cliff so that will be quite a
trip we'll see what happens with that
all right I'm going to say goodbye to
all of you and end the stream and thanks
for all of your questions and hopefully
you got some answers that that you got
something out of